doesn't matter what time what they
or should i not say i don't mind jewish
not jewish whatever you need we're here
to help anyone who has not had coven
they call this number they'll get out
was this the best year do you think
they always come to the rescue so this
is how it's done
what don't you guys do we enjoy every
minute of life we're available 24 7 365.
how does this get funded close to a
quarter of a million dollars usually
sitting two members
what's going on in here this is an
office on wheels
[Music]
89 a night new york city
coveted times very beautiful suite
but this video is not about hotel rooms
in new york city
it's about the hasidic jewish world in a
separate universe they've set up for
themselves
so obviously they have their own
religious traditions
they have their own media and they also
have the
chaverum and the chavera means friends
and what the friends do is help each
other out
so basically from my understanding it's
a set of services
for example you get a flat tire the
cheverum comes
you're an older woman who needs her
groceries brought up the stairs
in comes the cheverum plumbing issues
so today we're going to get in with the
hawaii
we're going to cruise around over the
river in new jersey
and see what this organization is all
[Music]
about
[Music]
the man the legend hey good morning how
are you
what are we doing slummy today oh man
first of all i would love to give you a
hug
are we allowed here can we you had
coveted
an exciting day should i not take off my
math we're outside okay we are outside
so i'll tell you what we're doing today
there's a concept in judaism that we
have
613 commandments we are supposed to do
some of them are positive commandments
some of them are negative commandments
the
one of the most important ones is called
the
in english it would mean love your
fellow person as if the same way you
love yourself
naseedic rabbis the scenic masters
explain that
you can't love anyone else unless you
love yourself
you want someone to have a smile you
have to give them a smile if you want to
be able to help somebody you have to
first be able to help yourself
when the plane's going down put your own
mask exactly so you have to be filled
with love and then you can love everyone
else there is a lot of kindness in the
hasidic community and the jewish
community in general and there's a lot
of kindness all over the world but i
think
one of the very special things about the
hazard community there's
an extra special amount of kindness and
you're going to see that today
[Music]
okay
[Music]
your destination is on the right looks
like a rental car operation they got all
these cars coming in here that's just
all the volunteers okay let's do it
hello
okay hello you had coveted
how was it was it was it as great as
everyone says it is
peter how are you santinello nice to
meet you
yeah hi
i want to see what you guys are doing
here your operation so guys we got the
command center what does that mean
what's going on in here this is an
office on wheels
okay literally an office on wheels
there's a good game going down
on this truck you'll see we have
multiple radios because it's owned by
hawaiian
rocklin but we have to participate with
quite a few agencies
so we're going to have over here usually
sitting two members
one member will be focusing on the
physical hikers as you can see the map
and the map they have the gps's every
team goes out with a gps
and they communicate by text because the
server is not always the best there
last week was monday night in the middle
of the night
and we had an artistic child
who left the house mom tried to do her
best to lock all the doors
the child got out of the house around i
would say 2 45 in the morning i remember
i was sleeping my radio went off
and call came out we had an autistic
child left the house
four minutes in the past middle of the
night we all jumped out
geared up and it wasn't cold weather
half sleepy but we're out there the only
thing what the
mother recognized is it was a red
pajamas and
yellow cracks okay a black down
three minutes after the call came out
thank god we located the child
return it to mama safely as you can see
this map this covers
pride of it it's easy that swamp paper
big territory i'd say miles
up and down a motor to new city going
down to wesley hills for shea homestead
and you're over here now located in
muncie we do operate 24 7
24 hours a day seven days a week now
let's go outside a little
i'll share with you three stories we
have our vehicle okay it's called squad
eight
oh one thing i want to say who who's had
who has not had covet
everyone's head covered this is the
safest place
absolutely for me to be all right salome
gave me the
the kobe guarantee in there so uh yeah
you're not gonna catch me
let me share with you a very interesting
story why we have all kind of different
equipment by the way i would say this
truck is worth
close to a quarter of a million dollars
whichever tool you can think of we have
generator provides electric why do we
need it
somebody's on life support in the middle
of the night got a blackout as you can
see all electricity goes to the
old-fashioned ways
power lines a tree hit the power line
from the high winds
grandma's on life support what would be
the regular option the regular option
would be
9-1-1 thank you for the ambulance what
take her to the hospital why should we
take remember to the hospital she won't
need
electricity we hook up this machine to
the life support
grandma can stay home all right then we
have those calls
constantly usually these are usually
used for happy things you should know
yeah well that's what your religion's
about yes happiness
happiness and kindness kindness all
right and we don't charge a book for it
that's
that's the sweetest part you're helping
a lot of grandmas grandmas
they keep mentioning grandma these
specific tools
yeah i would say for more elderly all
right
all right let's go let's show you a
little more
people these are all volunteers
so you guys all live in the community
you have jobs here
you give a certain time every week a
little bit of time every week
should we sum up this truck yeah any
situation no one is prepared for
this truck has everything prepared for
that enjoy do you have lunch for us
lunch lunch post your lunch the only
thing destructible
no no no we have food
these are ear jacks they work off of a
compressor it's a lot more powerful than
the typical jack that we have across we
can pick up a few
thousand pounds so who's who's paying
for all of this
the community you guys all all pitch in
huh
yep that's how it works we have a full
truck of generators in case people on
life support now we have when there's
there was the covert going on
and then we had a blackout people on the
life support so we had to provide them
with generators
we had a blackout here that lasted over
a week we had volunteers driving around
refilling the gas tanks they kept
calculation of when they filled it up
last
one was the next refill it needs and
they had volunteers 24 7. they were
driving around for
i believe it was a full week if not more
just refilling the generators
you said everyone just everyone in the
community pays
some of their paycheck or how does this
get funded there's no paycheck you can
ask them but basically
people just give charities we do it we
do once a year we do a charity campaign
and then everyone here is a volunteer so
that doesn't cost anything
it operates here you have one in new
york city another city there's an israel
one there's a montreal there's all over
the first place the idea came from here
do you guys you have like a dispatch
here
so to be in the club you have to be
hasidic though no you don't have to be
acidic you have to be
a little willing to help exactly willing
to help
okay we have known we have known jewish
people as well
over the weekend we have six of shout
outs six six six
six of our guys are not jewish at all
you have to be able to do
all different kind of jobs flat tires
control animal control squirrels birds
into the house raccoons
unclogged toilets and much more
what don't you guys do i don't know yet
medical
medical medical okay see medical is the
give us a call we're there to help
anyone in the community
anyone in the community doesn't make a
difference jewish not jewish whatever
you need we're here to help anyone
when you call the hotline one of the
questions are not if you're jewish or
not okay
just if you need help no problem we take
life to the next step
we enjoy every minute of life if it
means a comfortable vehicle
we'll do it as well but it's a nice car
one thing
this takes you good and snow somebody
needs help with snow the vehicle
will be there if it's a small car the
vehicle won't make it
we're available 24 7 365. the pacific
families have
large families right right so you need
seven eight nine seats in the vehicle
and they do a lot of driving you know
they'll go to brooklyn to see the
grandfather so it has to be comfortable
acidic jews have a weakness for black
suvs
all right your name shirley wells surely
surly wells all right shirley what are
we doing i'm gonna
respond to some calls now so you just
got a bunch of guys on standby just
sitting in here waiting
ready to go not all the time sometimes
people most most of the times
people are at work or at home and you
just hear the radio and they go off
gotcha
surely how long have you been doing this
i'm
fresh in hawaii i'm here for seven
months
okay but i've been there i'm the rookie
exactly you came in
just in time for coving huh that's a
good i actually came
in not in the peak oh there's a call
here
and you're not available for an auto
lockout on goal or drive off olympia
so any unit available for auto locker
that means someone left
so this call is like a triple a call
except you don't charge
anything correct on the back five caller
the dispatcher acknowledges them three
to
five minutes approximately three to five
minutes for every type of call
any time no if it's an emergency call
obviously you're faster
but usually and if there's a member
right let's say there's a call comes in
right here i'm right here
yeah it's approximately three to five
for for lost car keys or something it's
within five minutes yep
geez that's a nice service yeah so it's
actually an incentive for people to move
to this area
right or should i not say that online
it could be this is a nice neighborhood
huh this
is and we're gonna make the first ride
onto golar drive
so do you feel uh a certain reward by
doing this
i feel just accomplished my day is fully
accomplished
so oh that's the vehicle okay the
that's the pickup truck that's waiting
for the water lockout
we're gonna pull right in here and let's
see how the members approach
okay
he's in the middle of work in the middle
of the day oh responding to this
auto lock out of this person hey you
call havan right yes i don't know i just
ran out i just went inside for a second
i got locked out
those keys aren't happening they come
right away they open
how fast usually i called four minutes
ago five minutes ago they said they're
responding they're gonna
have someone open he said he said five
minutes
like is the the far extreme they're
always in less than five
as fast as he can they know people get
blackout it happens
comes right over
and you got you guys take this seriously
you got a full team out here
is this is this stage is this staged it
happens
they told me i think how many 31 000
calls in the last year
all day every day 32 000 okay
so this is how it's done huh little pump
it bag
you gave them a challenge with the tin
windows oh i'm sorry
have you ever used them for anything
else yes i have flat tires they come
they change your tires even when i'm in
the middle of the highway i pull them up
at night it doesn't matter what time
what they they always come for you
and they fix
oh you keep hitting the lock button go
drop higher
[Music]
so yesterday was just a regular day
nothing nothing
very serious at 8 30 p.m
um there was 193 calls already at 8 30
p.m that was a november 24th
yeah nice we got it thank you so so much
was that a hard one it was a hard card
it has the cars with windows
usually we pull the handle and this
handle is a very difficult handle okay
the pole are your favorite figures yeah
how are you feeling so
the best they always come to the rest
you have them to the rescue always
so sorry again you have your keys yeah
yeah
have a nice day thank you now we go back
to work
wait up where do you think you're going
to next i don't know
we'll see we'll find out we can never
know what we're going next to
this caller is now on his way back to
work or whatever it is
so it's a i mean i've called them in the
past like i got a flat tire on the uh
on a highway in new york city a couple
of weeks ago and
they don't charge for the service
obviously but sometimes people will
like if you want to give a member they
won't they will not take money from you
right
it's free the if you give them money
they will give it towards the
organization to buy more equipment or
whatever but it's uh
absolutely free service surly shirley
what is this
i'll tell you when we come out okay
so this is the dispatch center where 24
hours a day someone's sitting
in this dispatch room and dispatching
out
uh calls that come in people that need
help
127 dispatch center okay
so this is where dispatcher sits now
uh-huh
no problem cause if you need anything
else thank you
during the day usually just a standard
day i would say a quality five minutes
okay if there's any
like major weather outside any any other
thing else
going on in you know in the area we
would get close to like
two three calls a minute i've been doing
that for six years
what do you feel doing it um it's
amazing it used to be much quieter i
used to be able to do other things while
dispatching now
the community you know it's grown and
we cover much larger areas and
that's why it's usually very busy
they're they're all amazing they all
work with each other they know their
strength they know their location they
know what tools they have in the car
most of them are trained for the basics
then there are some things that
people who specialize in certain things
right some are very good at the search
and rescue we have our hiking team
so they go out for training like once or
twice a month like lost hikers or people
yes we have a couple of these parks
surrounded okay close by
and they all keep on doing training and
exercise they have all type of equipment
tracking devices anybody in the
community knows they call this number
anything but medical emergency they'll
get out to jews and non-jews alike
yes we help everyone that calls in
absolutely fantastic
um in this area the rocking county area
we have mostly jews in here okay
but absolutely in 36 hours you raise
this yes
unbelievable and you do this every year
we do it
mostly once a year was this the best
year do you think yes absolutely
if you're looking out of the outdoors
with a bunch of little kids and this is
the only one who got you into the house
you can't say no to such an organization
okay we have a low
air emergency and no call is too small
hello you have
usually your tire takes about 35 psi
instead of this this caller going to a
gas station paying
50 cents or a dollar for the four
minutes of the year
he calls havarium they're right over
here and you spend give him something
three dollars in gas but you feel good
and you're helping the community
that's how you save me instead of going
to
the gas station right
all right hold up thank you so much all
right guys
thank you so much thank you take care
all right guys that's haveram a very
interesting
uh very efficient service
in the community and if you want to
support them
right you guys got a link you got a page
to go to link below
and if you want to support this channel
peter santaniello
while i have a patreon page behind the
scenes footage
direct dming or if you just want to
support
feel free to go there thanks for
watching another very
interesting day in the hasidic world
until the next one
[Music]
here we go here we go
the highlight of the